take a pause here it really is just a
week and a half or so before christmas
and wait until next year to have a
bigger discussion on this or what is his
view of senator schumer's you know still
a hope which seems fleeting at this
point to get this done by christmas well
uh leader schumer continues to press
forward with uh getting this done making
progress in advance of christmas and
we're fully supported with that
but if it goes into the new year does
the president believe that that would be
better to preserve this agenda i mean
senator manchin this morning is
saying that he has serious reservations
about this and believes it essentially
needs to go back to the drawing board in
some respects well i'm of course not
going to speak for senator manchin i
know you're not asking me to do that but
we're continuing to support leader
schumer's effort to move this forward
and we are going to continue to play a
constructive role in that what else can
the white house do to make the case that
this will not um impact inflation that
seems to be a big concern of senator
mansions and of course others
well what we've been trying to do and
i'm sure the president if this is part
of the of what senator manchin would
like to discuss will make this case
directly as well that is to highlight
the fact that it's not just us but it is
a range of economists seven a 17 excuse
me uh nobel laureates who have conveyed
this will help address inflation over uh
the long term and that when we're when
we talk about inflation and and this may
be the way that the president and
senator manchin can discuss this in a
more accessible and human way
it's about how we lower costs for the
american people and people who are
looking planning they're looking at
their
budgets for next year maybe the first
quarter of next year the first half of
next year and they're trying to figure
out how to pay for child care and
they're trying to figure out how to make
sure they can put food on the table and
this
buildback better plan will help lower
costs for people across the country that
is fundamentally what it will do so we
will continue to make that case publicly
and privately to senator manchin as well
on the mansion uh conversation you said
the president's gonna be making his
argument directly as the argument he has
been making over the last several weeks
it seems based on what the senator said
this morning that he's uh pretty unmoved
in his positions right now so
have you where do you see signs of
potential movement here or is the
president bringing anything new to this
negotiating table today i wouldn't see
this as a negotiating table as much as a
conversation between uh two uh two
people who have been in public life for
some time and
have had good faith discussions directly
and this is just a continuation of that
given that and given on the issue of the
child tax credit it does seem likely
that this 20
deadline may come and go is there
anything
that the white house can do to provide
some relief for these families or
anything that can be done if in fact
these payments are appalled
well clearly the president wants to see
the child tax credit extended that's why
he proposed in this package and
clearly that's why a number of members
of the senate want to get this done
as soon as possible the president
supports that we of course need 50 votes
in order to do that so we're continuing
to work through the process of getting
there but if that deadline doesn't seem
to be enough so far to get manchin to
come around you know he's made clear he
wants to get this right it doesn't seem
that he's uh in a rush necessarily to
compromise he's not going to put a
certain deadline on this uh doesn't it
seem likely that this isn't going to
happen before the holiday i don't think
we need we're in a place to make that
prediction from here nor is anyone at
this point in time i mean the president
supports this package of course because
it includes an extension of the child
tax credit but also because it will
lower the cost of prescription drugs of
child care of elder care of housing
key components that are impacting people
across this country
he thinks that's a pretty compelling
case the american public agrees they
like all of those components too
but he also understands how the
legislative process works and we're
going to work that day by day go ahead
would the white house be okay if
congressional democrats move the
stand-alone
piece of legislation and extended those
tax credits we're not at that point
right now right now we're continuing to
press to get bill back better through
the senate uh leader schumer has
advocated for that and that's what we're
working on at this moment over the
weekend when he first spoke about the
storms he was also asked about ukraine
and russia
is there an active plan
to deploy american forces to eastern
black nato countries if russia
forays into ukraine he suggested that
there was something like that in the
works and we're just seeking some
clarification yeah well i appreciate you
seeking clarification i think as as our
national security advisor has touched on
and i don't think we've uh tried to hold
back from uh there are a number of nato
partner countries of course in eastern
europe eastern flank countries as you
just referred to them
and what happened if you look back post
2014 is a lot of these nato partner
countries were looking for reassurance
we're looking to plus up the presence
there are we're looking for um you know
additional rotational deployments and
certainly that is on the table uh should
russia decide to invade ukraine um
i won't ask again about
that better but i didn't ask go ahead
okay
there's another aspect of this sure
where um whether or not democrats can
include a work permit program for
undocumented immigrants in the plan
still waiting on the parliamentarian
decision but there are members of the
democratic party saying ignore that and
include some kind of pathway to
citizenship in this legislation the
president's support
well i think we're in the process we're
in now which you're very familiar with
and others are is we're waiting the
parliamentarian is doing her work uh in
reviewing a number of the components
that are currently in the package we
have to wait for that to complete itself
it's good it's going to take a little
bit more time but that you can't put a
bill on the floor before that process is
complete there was another round of
stories over the weekend about the
political fate of the president and the
vice president
and who might run in 2024
and it quotes a lot of
other democrats or people who work for
them
what is the white house's message to
those democrats
the white house's message is we're
focused right now on what the american
people elected the president to do less
about just over a year ago which is to
get covet under control to put people
back to work
and to help give people some breathing
room and we hope other people keep their
focus on that as well did they knock it
off
is that speculation the president has
every intention of running for
reelection so that's the other message
for them
you're not going to believe this i have
another question about buildback better
i'm ready uh so the president says that
the buildback better is not going to add
a penny to the deficit the cbo has this
new score uh where they assume that
social programs are going to be made
permanent and in that case it would add
almost three trillion dollars so does
that mean that president biden will
commit that these programs are not going
to be made
permanent
well first of all what we're talking
about here is a fake cbo score that is
not based on the actual bill that
anybody is voting on this was a ask
request by senator graham to score a
bill that is not currently being debated
uh that is her his prerogative to to to
do
but what our focus is on is on the
existing bill that will lower the
deficit uh that will also over an
additional 10 years pay for the two
trillion dollar tax cuts that
republicans didn't pay for they're
welcome for that so i would say peter to
your uh question the president has
conveyed very clearly multiple times
publicly that he would like programs if
they're extended to be paid for that
remains his commitment but it's
important to understand that when you
when anybody raises a question about
this new cbo score it is a fake score
about a bill that doesn't exist uh and
we should really focus on the actual
bill everybody's uh going to vote on and
considering in congress right now okay
another topic is vice president hare
still in charge of addressing the root
causes of migration from el salvador
honduras and guatemala she is and i just
announced a commitment that she's
announcing this afternoon
why is it that she has not spoken to the
president of guatemala since june that's
six months well i know that i i did see
this kind of strange report uh from the
president of guatemala saying that uh
he's had no contact with the white house
which is inaccurate
he said uh vice president harris he has
not spoken to her and if she's in charge
why why is that
well we have had a range of
conversations peter i think as it
reflected in our readout we put out last
week with our national security advisor
with the vice president's national
security advisor with our nsc senior
director juan gonzalez uh we put out an
extensive readout of that uh just last
week and we'll continue that high level
of engagement okay uh final topic do you
think it's possible that big cities are
dealing with these smash and grab
robberies right now increase
in criminal activity because some
prosecutors are too soft on crime
i would say we have seen i'm not going
to attribute the reasoning from here
what i will tell you is we have seen an
increase in crime over the course of the
pandemic there are a range of reasons
for that um and what we're our focus is
on is what we can do to address it the
president has proposed additional
funding in the budget to make sure local
police departments and cops have the
funding they need
we have also worked directly with police
departments in areas where they are
seeing the highest impact of the crime
the retail threat which theft which we
have great concern about that's what our
focus is on currently is action and
doing what we can to make sure the
funding is out there to the communities
that need it the most but i guess what
good does it do if you're going to give
police departments extra money if they
arrest bad guys and they bring them to
jail and then they're not prosecuted
they're just right back out on the
streets
i think peter what our focus is on is
making sure that
the local
leaders the police officers and
departments who know what they need for
these communities have the assistance
and the funding they need and that's
what we're working around the clock on
so the final one would be just in the
last week
we saw a new york post item about a
pickpocket with more than 30 arrests
back out on the street
we've seen an arsonist burn down a half
a million dollar christmas tree in new
york city back out on the streets does
the president think
that that's good governing
again i think i've spoken to the
president's concerns about retail theft
if you have specific and and the actions
we've taken for specific cases i would
point you to the local police
departments or the department of justice
go ahead kelly on the mansion
conversation today what's the format for
that you mentioned conversation not
meeting is this by phone in person
what's the setup it is a phone call it
is a phone call so they will be
conversing over the phone
and uh
is that typically just the two of them
or would you have legi affairs and
others involved as well it really
depends on the conversation they've had
one-on-one conversations and sometimes
there's additional staff available in
case there are follow-up questions i can
check and see if there's more details on
that and the president talked about
going to
kentucky on wednesday but not having
decided exactly where he's going we know
that he doesn't want to interfere with
things on the ground do you know what
sort of
um
visit he is looking for he said he
hasn't decided yet on where he wants to
go do you know what what sort of um
type of impact he wants to make by going
in person sure well he and and he is
very mindful as you've heard him say a
couple of times over the weekend he does
not want to pull resources away from uh
the rescue and recovery efforts so i
think that was what was on his mind we
did finalize the travel and announce it
was to for campbell kentucky for a storm
briefing and to mayfield and dawson
springs kentucky to survey storm damage
and i would expect while he's there he
will receive an update from local
authorities on what their needs are see
local elected officials and discuss in
person with them and make sure they're
getting what they need from the federal
government and i think as you've seen
him seen him do kelly and i can't
remember if you were on the trip i think
you were uh when we went to when he went
to the northeast uh he also wants to
hear directly from people and he wants
to offer his support directly to them
people who have gone through over the
last couple of days uh really incredible
challenges losing their home losing
loved ones uh losing parts of their
community that they've grown up with and
i think he wants to offer his support uh
directly to them as well so i would
expect it's a combination of those
pieces you expected to extend to
illinois at some point or other states
that have been hit by this or is that to
be determined
it's certainly room he remains open to
that it's to be determined and it uh i
think this trip is being done given that
the vast impact of the storm damage and
in parts of kentucky
chad the president suggested he may have
more to say on the filibuster
does he have a view of on this so-called
carvel to the filibuster rule as
voting rights and do you think this may
come up in his conversation with senator
manchin
uh i know that uh they will be talking
about a range of things uh of
legislative components and of course
build back better is front and center to
that and certainly uh voting rights is a
priority to the president and i know
it's something that senator manchin is
committed to i don't have anything to
update you on in terms of the
legislative process and the president's
view on that at this point this is
brian diese's favorite subject do you
expect any announcement this week on the
fed nominees
i i don't have a day uh for you uh but
certainly that is something that we're
looking to get done uh soon and
hopefully before the president and
everyone leaves for a time with their
families over the holidays
go ahead
thank you i i wanted to know i know you
got asked about this earlier but do you
have any information on like next steps
when it comes to russia diplomatic stuff
for sure russia and nato uh are there
any plans for more talks more meetings
uh of that nature
sure well let me give you because
there's a there's a lot of different
moving parts at the same time right now
so this weekend secretary blinken was at
the g7 foreign ministers meeting in
liverpool to discuss our cooperation on
a comprehensive response to russia's
military buildup uh there was a joint
statement released uh calling on russia
to de-escalate pursue diplomatic
channels abide by its international
commitments on transparency of military
activities as president biden did in his
call with president putin and the
foreign ministers as they were meeting
and in in this statement also warned
that any use of force to change borders
is strictly prohibited under
international law and that russia should
expect that further military aggression
against ukraine would have massive
consequences so that was kind of
reiterating what the president conveyed
to president putin and what he conveyed
so from the state department assistant
secretary for the bureau of european and
eurasian affairs dr karen donfried is in
kiev today and will visit moscow
tomorrow to meet with senior government
officials to discuss russia's military
buildup and to reinforce the united
states commitment to ukraine's
sovereignty she will emphasize that we
can make diplomatic progress on entering
enter ending the conflict in the donbass
through implementation of the minsk
agreements in support of the normandy
format following that trip she's going
to travel to brussels to consult with
nato allies and eu partners which has
been kind of how we have approached the
sedate additionally our national
security team is continuing to have
extensive conversations with our
european allies and partners uh
throughout the day and that will
continue as well so day by day what we
are working to do here is have keep the
lines of diplomatic engagement open have
those conversations with europeans but
also directly with the ukrainians and
the russians
and continue to look and pursue a path a
diplomatic path forward and just when it
comes to booster shots obviously cases
are rising there are big concerns about
omicron
there is a push in the uk to get
all of their citizens get them with the
booster shots yeah there it has been
very slow in the u.s for eligible people
to get booster shots is there
any plan for a bigger
push from the white house from the
federal government to get people to get
the booster shots
we are that is absolutely what we're
focused on uh and we've seen an uptick
recently it's not as you said nearly
where it needs to be in terms of
everybody eligible getting a booster
shot and we know that that can be
protective in against delta which is
still the predominant variant here but
also we're seeing increased it would be
increased protection against omicron
even as we learn more
we have seen
if you look at seniors um we've seen
that about 60 of eligible uh who are in
uh
nursing home facilities uh have been
have received a booster actually it's
higher than that
actually sorry uh 91 for single
facilities have completed their booster
clinics that's a good sign right for
older more vulnerable populations and
we've also seen a number of states
execute very strong programs that can be
good models west virginia maryland ohio
and north carolina are also nearly
complete with their booster rollout um
but we need we are continuing to press
publicly privately with governors as
you've seen us talk a lot about this uh
nationally uh because we know that more
people get boosted more protected
thanks jen the president has had to
address a series of natural disasters
other severe weather occurrences from
wildfires to hurricanes and now these
tornadoes and each time we've heard him
talk about how i think he said this on
saturday this shouldn't be
partisan moments we're not you know
republicans and democrats but we've also
heard him also on many of these
occasions talk about the demonstrated
effect of climate change so two
questions one
what if anything can we expect to hear
from the president when he goes to
kentucky on wednesday about specifically
about climate change can you talk about
how he balances those two imperatives of
trying to strike this unifying note but
talking about an issue that you know
frankly is a partisan that has caused a
partisan divide
you're right i i i'm not going to get
ahead of what he's going to say in
kentucky and as i noted in response to
kelly's question i mean that visit is
really about him receiving an update of
the work that's happening on the ground
hearing directly from leaders on what
they need more from the federal
government if anything and he's going to
be very responsive to that and really
trying to be a source of comfort to
people who have gone through a
devastating couple of days in their
communities
so it's not an opportunity he's not
going to give a major speech while he's
there i will note and he's been asked
this a couple of times over the last few
days and when we were in the north when
he was in the northeast several months
ago what has been striking to him and to
all of us is just the sheer impact of uh
of the climate uh changes in the climate
uh and the crisis that is uh is the
climate currently on uh on in on
communities across the country on the
cost to communities on these major
weather events that have impacted such a
growing percentage of
we're getting a little groovy in here i
like it okay
[Laughter]
it's kind of exactly what we needed
right now um
it's all good
yes
i was enjoying it thoroughly we should
turn it back on in a few minutes um
anyway
um
there are some really startling
statistics i actually will get these all
out to all of you about the percentage
of people in this country who have been
impacted by severe weather events it is
increased over the course of time and
the president will talk about this more
and it is not a political thing because
look at the communities that have been
impacted red blue purple no color at all
communities that don't consider
themselves uh political in any way shape
or form and uh this is certainly a
driving reason why we need to do more uh
to address the climate crisis but let me
get back to you with those statistics
which i think have really struck the
president as the reason why we need to
act along the same lines the president i
think said on saturday that he would
seek uh some input from the epa about
whether these specific tornadoes were
caused by climate change how much of a
direct tie there was there has he gotten
any feedback from them and if so what
they informed him about i think he just
answered a similar question this morning
as well uh and it is something that
he'll just continue to discuss with his
climate advisors and teams and obviously
local leaders as well but i don't think
there's any new assessment of it he just
knows that because of the change in
climate because of the threat the
climate crisis poses that we're we have
seen more extreme weather events and
that is a reason uh to act
go ahead um have the white house team
been in touch with senator manchin or
his staff about his inflation concerns
and if so can you tell us what exactly
they have been telling uh senator
we have been in regular contact with
senator manchin from a range of
officials from
the white house including members of our
policy team members of our legislative
team to address any questions that he
may have and without getting into
private discussions i can assure you
that they have conveyed that
acting now on buildback better that that
inflation concerns the the that's re why
we should act on buildback better now
they've of course cited the 17 nobel
laureates they've cited how it will
reduce costs and a lot of the cases
we've made publicly are also uh you know
the the information that we've shared
privately as well and just um to go back
to one of the questions from the front
row if uh the democrats in congress were
to pass a
one-year extension of the child tax
credit would the president insist that
be paid for and fully offset
it's it's not currently being proposed
or considered the president has conveyed
that he wants to see any extension of
these programs paid for that's a that's
his fundamental approach to legislating
and policy making uh but i'm not going
to get into a hypothetical at this point
in time okay last one here and then
we'll wrap it up okay i have a couple
quick ones for me and then i'm the
cooler so it's one from someone else
okay
so on this executive order that he's
about to sign yeah um what's the
strategy to do this now and can you give
us any sense of a timeline more specific
timeline on implementing it or
consequences that federal agencies would
face if they don't follow through
uh well it's going to take six to 12
months to implement it it's a priority
for agencies so it will depend it's
going to be a
implementation component
there will be a little different right
depending and agencies will have a more
direct and specific assessment about how
long it will take but some of this is
getting programs or online systems up
and running so that they can be
implemented and i would say that the
reason to do it now is uh the
president's someone who has been in
government as vice president for eight
years obviously 36 years in the senate
and he's a firm believer we can always
make government work more effectively
and efficiently technology is a way to
do that in many ways to make it easier
simpler more accessible for people
whether they're seniors who are trying
to get their social security benefits or
people just applying to renew their
passport and i'll tell you i was very
happy to hear that so that's good news
uh so that's something that he has long
been a believer in uh it's something
that took a little bit of uh of work
internally to make sure we had the
systems in place to get it going and
then one quick other one from akali the
canadian government wrote to senate
leadership and committee chairs last
week to threaten retaliatory tariffs uh
and potentially retracting certain usmca
dairy concessions if the ev tax credit
in bbv is passed
um what's the white house reaction to
this and has there been any discussion
about extending eligibility to canadian
assembled vehicles and batteries for the
same credits
uh i know we talked about this a little
bit when uh the prime minister trudeau
was here uh just a couple of weeks ago
the president advocated for these tax
credits because he wants to make it more
affordable for the american people to
purchase electric vehicles and because
he feels it's
an area of a huge opportunity an
industry of huge opportunity for
american automakers we have a good
working relationship with the canadians
uh we had a good conversation about it
but i don't have any additional policy i
would expect or changes to that uh sorry
this was short today thank you everybody
uh
is
[Music]